الطب والتجديديه يعرف على انه عمليه
استبدال او تجديد الخلايا او الانسجه
والاعضاء البشريه التالفه بسبب المرض او
العمر كذلك الاصابه
لمحاوله استعاده وظائفها الطبيعيه قبل
تراجع كفاءتها بشكل مشابه للاليات التي
تساعد الجسد على شفاء نفسه اللي طب
التجديديه هو مجال جديد نسبيا خرج للنور
لاول مره في التسعينيات ويمكن ان يساعد
على التحسن بدون ادويه او حتى جراحه ابحث
في الطب التجديده لا تزال جاريه لكن
العلاج بالخلايا الجذعيه اصبح شائعا وفي
يزرع العلماء خلايا جذعيه في المختبر
خلايا مثل الموجوده في القلب او الدم او
الاعصاب حسب الحاله وتزرع لاحقا للمريض
للطب التجديدي يمكن ان يساعد في علاج داء
السكري من النوع الاول واصلاح انسجه القلب
والاوعيه الدمويه انواع معينه من السرطان
كما يمكن ان يحسن من كفاءه جهاز المناعه